after a five-day pause ccsd students and
teachers they are back in school but
some are raising a red flag saying
social media shows anything but back to
business bianca holman live from near
canyon springs high school with more
bianca so we received a facebook message
describing and claiming that there were
students during first period in the gym
here at the high school because there
were no teachers there were teachers
that were out it's that situation that
concerns many people
the kids on the skateboards
hanging out
chatting laughing talking miranda hatter
feels like most surprised to see teens
at the park and not in school and even
more concerned to hear about social
media messages describing canyon springs
high school a viewer shared their
grandson's first class was held in the
gym because there was no teacher it's
really sad because the teachers are
scared and i can understand that with
the pandemic the way it is right now
yeah teachers are still kind of
frightened get sad like i said i mean
kids they need to put the kids first
ccsd had a five-day pause to give staff
a chance to recover it also gave nurses
time to process calls related to covid
during the time off ccsd states 1068
employees were cleared to return out of
1409. hatter worries about the confusion
i don't see it getting i hope it get
better i pray it get better but we don't
know
so we reached out to the district about
that facebook message about what was
happening here at the high school we
have not heard back when we do we will
keep you updated online bianca holman
live local now